e tu che fai io lo dice lui glielo dice
guardate la domanda può sembrare stupida
però non lo è
nel senso che quanto sta parlando con
una persona ci sta raccontando quelle so
quello che avete fatto quel giorno
scuola è un certo punto apre apre le le
fauci e cioè tutto quello che ho sentito
svanisce di colpo tutto quello di cui
state parlando non ha più importanza
perché l'unica cosa che riesce a vedere
l'unica cosa sulla quale si è
concentrato il pezzo di verde di chissà
che cosa perché poi dici te le fai della
sera che cosa staranno e sei lì a
chiederti che diamine si sa che cosa sia
e soprattutto se si bisogna dirlo se non
bisogno di dirglielo
cioè diciamolo nel senso la prima cosa
che ti verrebbe da fare senza scusami ti
è rimasto incastrato tra i denti in
pranzo e allora cerca di trovare un
eretico sis castri con l'ombra bile dai
lenti ok è che ti è rimasto il party si
mangiato poi il mac pietà pro ii di
mcdonald no ma comuni tv commerciali
capitato duemila volte sono che dopo un
po lo spettacolo diventa l'elemento
origine insostenibile per la vista è
ripugnante un po però queste cose non le
si fanno male perché poi se ha paura di
ferire i sentimenti di eliminare il
rapporto come se ti rapporto possa
essere rovinato da che ne so una cozza
appiccicata sull'eccessivo certo non è
carino non è il massimo che si possa
avere una persona allo stesso tempo
certo tu poi non imbarazzo ce l'hai
cioè ti viene tipo da sentirti so so che
non ti sei lavato quel giorno ma che si
è lavato davvero ancora peggio però non
viene dice queste cose perché hai sempre
paura un attimo di offendere quindi cosa
fa tinte a fissare finché lo che ne
pensi cosa è chiusa la faccenda
oh sì sì sì
la cosa più [ __ ] e che se lo dici romani
in terapia dallo psicologo per chissà
quanti mesi mentre se non glielo 10 non
finiti si incazza vino contro non è
detto perché su questo ce lo stavo con
un amico ok e per tutto il geloso qui
aveva qualcosa è appiccicato sulla
guancia di poco tone che uscì una
puntina era strano non l'ho detto per
tutta la giornata anzi mi sono un certo
punto pure abituato a vederlo comunque a
specie di baffo d'oca che che compariva
di lato un certo punto dopo essere stati
praticamente ovunque
dopo aver esposto la sua faccia al mondo
intero
mi fa figli faccio ok e lo spetto non
sapevo che dopo poco mi sarebbe calato
un lembo scusami tanto non vedi i miei
oggi dove cui medio ma non era un pelo
bianco un baffo di foca e se fosse mi
avresti moore è potuto dire
morale della favola se vostra di con una
caccola che gli pende dal naso un pelo
pubblico incastrato fra gli incisivi
portatevi e scappate prima che se ne
possa accorgere perché se no la colpa
sarà solamente vostra